you know every someone told me ever done
welcome everyone to another episode of
rent cafe I believe this is 23 now right
guys I don't even know I put in 23
hopefully it's the right one
well yeah what a time to be alive
everyone ran cafe number 23 this is an
epic --all epical occasion and joining
me today yeah I don't say I pick anymore
because everyone says I say epic coal
it's like emphasizes it more but joining
us today we have a new special guest a
first-timer here on ranch cafe Lotus
from the nerdcore nerd corner what's up
Lotus it was poppy I'm actually
impressed you're the only person who's
ever tried to introduce me in a setting
in my channel properly on the first try
cuz apparently well cuz I think it's a
cool name so I remembered of course I
thought it was cool when I came up with
it too but apparently no one can say it
except you you know the cool people we
get each other man you know we just got
to be on that same wavelength I dig it
exactly absolutely and this for this
episode of ranked of everyone we're
gonna be talking about roughly we always
go off topic you know how we do but
roughly we're gonna be talking about the
spring 2017 anime season so far how what
we're liking what we're not not liking
what we're expecting in the future and
so on excuse me
and actually we have a recon with us
today I'm glad that he's here enemy
recon because he yeah does look you
reviews a lot of anime on his channel so
you know he watches a lot of season
right I'm watching about three right now
and I've seen the first episodes for
like two more however I know recon
you're well worst worst unseasonal anime
and so we're gonna get into it but yeah
recon what's up let's introduce you next
Oh how's it going with festival funnies
every gone and yeah I basically do lot
of reactions and anime top tens and you
should check out my channel but uh how
are we gonna start this off am I gonna
like talk about what anime am I gonna
talk about the enemy we're gonna we're
gonna start off by also introducing Mac
lot and Briggs but then we're gonna get
right into it you don't have who needs
who needs him back what's up my man
how's it going on you working a lot
look sorry what you cut out a bit I said
good to have you here I know you've been
working a lot yeah it's it's been a busy
two weeks but but like in a good way I
guess but it's good to be back it's
gonna be back I know it's only been a
week but it feels like it's true man
without you like Mac we started this
idea together for rent cafe I will never
forget that bro I won't either I might
forget it but I'm gonna be like really
really old and senile so if that's the
case then I'm sorry but we'll see we'll
see when the time comes
sounds good sounds good all good to hug
anyway and we also have brigs what up
bricks from all day anime what's up man
it's good to be back you know this drank
haha Thursday's aren't the same without
rank cafe you're my ultimate rival
remember that brick yes Briggs you not
make actually he could not make it
because as a vamp last week and Rika was
pissed he's like where's my rival Briggs
who believes Emilia is best girl I don't
know breaks recon sees a big rival how
do you feel
competition Emilia all the way she's
gonna have another girl aw like I'm not
worried about the competition rivalry
[ __ ] that three hours stream was
definitely not long enough on a black
criticai school by the way no neck I
can't believe you actually did that like
that stream was why were you aware yeah
yeah I was I wasn't there for the entire
thing but I was there for it got a
little heated at points is funny oh man
yeah I was gonna say like in case you
didn't know we had a like a two and a
half hour stream on black credit guys
Channel debating with notes I had notes
[ __ ] yes [ __ ] really did research
that's wild our research probe we got
Amelia
we got REM it was crazy it was a crazy
time
I guess not what I think about I'm like
what the [ __ ] were we thinking but it
was fun we just do a wife who where it's
like we she's running out of topics 23
episodes in wife--who wars why not it'll
give you an excuse to put big titties in
a thumbnail you feel me there you go
I don't need an excuse bro I
the same yo if you discuss big titties
than having big titties isn't clip it
anymore so you know no one can fault you
for that not it's not misleading right
it's not misleading right you know this
actual topic
yeah that's why like you know when I
discuss PewDiePie or something I'll just
put like some big ol big ol breasts on
there but yeah a bricks man how's it
feel bro how's it feel your channels
blowing up yeah I uh it doesn't feel
real it genuinely doesn't feel real like
except people are actually watching my
videos what some subject your videos
forever don't insult my intelligence
Hey many people who matter really
briefly on the point at one point Briggs
is gonna overtake me I'm gonna be so mad
he was I will really go way beyond just
the life avoids me he's gonna overtake
me can we all agree that if Briggs or
Tex recon Amelia's best girl no I I
don't think I said that word girl that
works I wouldn't have we with the Papio
hear me I don't know
I thought you legitimately think about
it 10,000 subscribers and Briggs is like
blown up and he's like almost there he
was like he's so close to reaching me
what number are you at right now
actually
I like seven thousand three hundred damn
I'm on that issue
gosh 8900 over here with my 4100 you
know oh yeah my way oldest Congrats on
4k I noticed you recently hit 4k right I
don't well yeah preciate humming
congratulations to this channel as well
for reach 11 K not too long ago as like
well thank you though I love to see
everybody growing in mac is almost a
2000 which means that he will still be
cosplaying as RAM and that is gonna be
yet another by the way can we I almost
don't even want to talk about it but it
needs to be discussed this [ __ ] dressed
up as [ __ ] man Bonner I saw it on
like roses like Instagram story or some
[ __ ] and I I was so confused I was like
hey he brought this [ __ ] to real life
and I was scarred okay no it was it
wasn't like I was already
dark place I was having a good day the
Sun was out the birds were chirping this
the Sun was singing you know had a
smiling face on it like there's some old
Disney cartoon you know I was having a
nice bowl of cereal then I see him with
his big-ass mustache dressed as Menma
and just turned my whole world upside
down just tore my whole vision asunder
my world came crashing down around me
just imagine this dude saying to you I
love you the kind of love where I want
to marry you stop who's good oh man mm
but you ruined all over walked back I
wanna that's that's that's what I came
to do I can I can I can't look at Menma
the same ever again you've destroyed her
neither can i man I can't of course all
I think about is myself now and I'd a
good thing is the good thing is that now
he's gonna do the same to REM so all the
REM fans are gonna have broken hearts
and me and bricks are gonna be like
cha-ching hold up that's that's assuming
I reach 2,000 subscribers by the Year
2029 that's a bit of an undertaking you
believe in your dog right do it if he
justices REM that means Mac right horror
is a REM femme that means you both both
of you uproar and pretty mom uh-huh gosh
I don't matter bio-rad phonetic here
you're kind of ripping that red a little
bit there like you think do you think
it's a coincidence that Briggs shot at
you out Mac at the beginning of his one
of his videos do you think it's a
coincidence that I feature you on my
week's best videos is because we're
gonna make sure you get to that mm my
friend we got to make sure well I'm
sorry I have such lovely people as my as
my as my broken uh Keys Thank You mr.
Brooks Oscar's I take that ya video I've
shouted your Lighting's gonna hit 100k
soon which will be my second video like
can't believe it yes just be much hey
don't forget rent cafe bro you know will
you be hey don't forget about the little
guys when you make it big homie yeah
don't forget us bro we want some cold
tails to ride we might just have to do a
rad cafe on my channel if I somehow
overtake take you guys yeah by the way
by the way we should do those are some
of these n streams if you dumb your
exams 90% let's do it up I'm down for
that I've actually just rewatched a
series again I'm hyped do you guys read
the manga row or I'm not
long and now I'm catching up to the
manga now I caught up this Irie watch a
series watch the OVA is and now I'm
reading the catching up to the manga so
that's good and of course breaked has
read it Briggs knows notice if you read
them on that you're absolutely welcome
welcome to come to the seven deadly sin
streams and I appreciate the invite but
I am NOT up to date I've only read up to
where season 1 ends so it's like the
first 12 or 13 volumes I mean if you
want to come by you can still come by
alright then appreciate it yeah
absolutely dude so uh spring out of it
yes bring anime but before that I got a
shout out to my girl for never world non
15 I'm kidding it's forgotten 915 aka
girl bro I see a I miss I said her name
wrong on with the last video and then
everyone laughed at me in discord for
two hours straight yeah birthed it my
fault it's not my fault
tired and on drugs guys but yeah spring
anime so I guess I'll start with it and
then we'll go to recon because he's seen
more spring anime than I think probably
any of us but I'm watching so far
regularly attack on Titan my hero
academia re-creators
and I've seen the first episode of
clockwork planet that sexy monk one I
want to say that I still haven't seen it
benefits of the spring anime I was like
I need I need this I need this in my
life right now
yeah I've seen like the first two of the
very short episodes and then like I've
seen like the ones that were out and
then after that I was kind of like like
like I was waiting for the new ones to
come up with her I didn't check back in
a while something to go back and so yeah
so I've seen like five or six so far at
least the first episode and I'm
regularly watching the other ones I love
attack on Titan so far all four episodes
have been insane like we've been doing
live reactions like ah me and my bro
here on the channel like actually going
live and chatting with people as we're
watching and it feels like it goes by
like 10 minutes and in reality take 25
minutes have gone by the episode is over
and I'm like damn and the action has
been so good you know the build-up to
the big reveals and stuff like I feel
like some mystery [ __ ] is gonna be read
soon like I'm really liking attack on
Titan I have to say it was worth the
wait
if it continues like this for all 12
episodes I'm gonna be psyched even
though there's only 12 and yeah
recreator so far pretty good umm the
first episode wasn't as good as I was
hoping it was it looks very much kind of
like otaku bait kind of uh you know your
classic no game no life type setup oh no
mr. nobody suddenly becomes important
for no reason whatsoever but um it is I
like it I'm a writer myself so I like
the whole concept of you know different
worlds coming to life
so yeah I'm enjoying that so far and my
yurikano with three creators I have you
watched all three episodes so far I've
watched the first two I'm just about
towards a third one today okay okay
that's good yeah and the other the other
one that I watching is mine here
academia but um I don't know man it's a
slow start for me is it just like that
showed to me is is a bit of a generic
shown and like I'm not much of a fan
like it takes way too long to build up
to something that interests me like in
the first season I really like the final
arc with the villains attacking like
that was dog having on the edge of my
seat but before that all the training
and build-up I wasn't feeling it that
much I think that cry baby I don't like
crying I agree with you that it is like
a generic showing like I like this
series but it's I don't know to me
there's nothing particularly special
like it's really enjoyable it's a lot of
fun I do enjoy it but there's nothing
super unique original about it to me
but I'd a lot of people say that it
feels slow - the more it builds up too
long but I don't know I never felt that
pacing issue like it seems well paced to
me I'm just really biased it's exactly
the type of anime like I I look for like
the whole like kind of like Weger guy a
little bit of cry-baby and then like
he's put in this situation where he
could become stronger and like his
dreams type of a thing like it reminds
me of Kenichi just worse I will say I
kind of like crybaby characters because
I like Kenichi I like Shinji I like God
some dead man wonder like all these
people up you were like oh he's so
annoying all he does is whine [ __ ] and
crime like I don't know I kind of like
ass character the home is not too much
and they're able to overcome it when it
matters right it's alright that's cool
though I mean just cuz it's a like a
generic trope or whatever doesn't mean
you can't like it right like yeah that's
nothing like a people always want to
call things like cliche generic and
call it bad for that reason like oh I
mean enemies been along for how long
everything you could possibly think of
has been done like I challenge anyone to
come up with an original anime concept
guaranteed it's been a tribe before it
so it's true it's very true and even if
you look at things like short on online
and you like oh that's a cool concept
you know there's so many other animated
did the same thing break even your cat
log horizon there's so many other of
those like even you kill right the
keeping you here right yeah off your
game world right so it's like it's been
done so many times so you're absolutely
right on that and it's not necessarily
that every anime that like I'm not one
of those like snobs that it's like oh
the anime has to be a masterpiece or I
hate it like everyone knows how much I
love Kay Jo and I'm afraid to admit it
can kill you on that Navin hey Jo gage
was hilarious it was amazing there needs
to be a season to not watch it it was
beautifully animated that was amazing
soccer good he even got a mangas
actually I especially loved the plot you
know the manga is actually getting
thrown thrown away because of how low
people are you know because it's not
doing well the mama Lackey gay what's
funny about that is that the manga got
cancelled because of poor sales but then
I read a report that said that they were
misreported the first time so does
something like 700 sales when it was
actually 7000 so was like someone put
the decimal in the wrong spot or some
[ __ ] like that
and so recently the Monica just made his
own clap back about why it was really
canceled and I forget the details but if
you look it up you like you could read
more into that but it's funny how it
went down yeah I think he said like he
clarified in that had nothing to do with
the anime that people before the anime
Minh started airing they were like we're
gonna cancel the manga so right like
they were against him from the start
like they want this negative Fisk yeah
exactly
but like like I said the anime was
hilarious and everyone who doesn't like
it as a pleb but moving on soul maka
said in the chat he said that he likes
characters to be individuals so he
doesn't like the whole you know cookie
cutter sort of cry-baby guided then when
it counts overcomes and like yeah I
don't know to me like I like I like
characters to have something special
like something that's just like do like
you know coming on my favorite character
of all time
or like Lelouch who is like an evil
genius in many ways light as well l-like
those tough characters like you
like he's weird in certain ways he's
Machiavellian he's like inspirational
that's what I looking Gators I don't
looking character it's like oh man this
guy is just like your everyday guy but
then buy some deus ex machina he becomes
this special chosen one type character
none not my cup of tea I guess but recon
let's go to you tell us your impressions
of the season so far and tell me why
you'll be with everything I just said I
can't agree with everything you said so
you're just wrong excited yeah he's
actually wrong in the sample and your
finger out of the series because you
know I uproar you need to know I'm
better than you I'm gonna anyways I've
watched boku no hero and I agree with
you actually it's kind of a slow start
but a dick pick up as soon as we got a
little bit more in-depth into the events
that going on you know the but multiple
of the racing events it my boy Todoroki
was badass yo he like froze the entire
field he III thought he was gonna win
him but no know where Elly was gonna win
because Deku did not even use his corks
a single time in that event and
literally just used like the power of
his brain mine was lucky enough to find
that piece of power
I miss Deku ex machina yeah yes thank
you
why don't I just put this the sheet of
metal on a bomb on a landmine and it
shouldn't magically fly me away like
Aladdin Scarface nothing look he just
like he just [ __ ] pull me up this is
gonna make me fly away like you know
just like flies over across [ __ ] go and
do the donkey just wins the entire race
but I would ask you though uproar what
did you think of the next event which is
the cavalry battle what did you think of
it so far like it looks interesting but
it's very like on the high school side
kind of like a hiatus on the high school
side but with special powers I like I
like that the show mixes up the high
school and and the fact that they want
to be professional are heroes that it's
like they're one of me that we want that
to be their career however I like the
hero and villain stuff played up more so
that's what I like the the villain of
arc at the end of the first season with
her outside of the school they're out of
their element and it's like oh [ __ ]
what's gonna happen like I really like
that are I did not specific like I like
the whole school build-up stuff probably
because I've seen so much school enemy
before it it's kind of like this this
doesn't add necessarily anything for me
yeah thank you I agree with you on that
like they're dead this shows definitely
more interesting outside of the school
like anything that takes place like
literally outside the school environment
is it's more interesting because it when
it's within school walls you're kind of
is like okay this is a controlled
environment nothing too crazy is really
gonna go down yeah let's move on to a
seminal heroine how to raise a boring
girlfriend season two anybody watch the
first season no I'm not hurt are you
freakin kidding me that's a really good
series really good series basically a
bunch of characters who create a video
game and does have you know that nice
edgy slice of Rhys romance and comedy in
it whether price okay
I said slice of life nice nice like a
surprise rice but nice slice of rice
it's a perfect side dish you know it
goes with any a really well just like a
sliver of the page there you go so since
you guys happen to watch so we'll move
on what about have you are you guys
watching
Roku Dena she um Akashic Akashic records
of a bastard magical instructor and no
been meaning to you yeah I need to tell
her all right now the only actual
madness of casuals the main character of
this series is one of the best I have
ever seen his name is Glen and from the
start of the episode when I watched this
I was like okay he's just another boring
[ __ ] I'm like okay yeah I don't
know this year's gonna go anywhere but
the way it has progress my boy Glen just
of
volved into greatness throughout the
series oh yeah he is so funny he is so
[ __ ] funny oh he is so brave like the
amount of like in a single episode he
took massive blows into his body and his
face became pale but he will not like
he's brave he won't he keeps getting
back up on his feet he won't give up and
to be honest that's what represents an
awesome main character as him so he's
neurotic um yes very much so
Deku um Shinji um or are Ilana cute it's
all like because I want to watch it I
still want to watch it but who's whose
idea was it to name the main character
Glenn don't ask me I mean it's look
alright epic hero he's gonna save the
day everything's gonna be awesome he's
gonna kick ass what do we know that we
don't know timeless let's just work okay
yeah but they say it already
I definitely like blended
to be honest I was surprised when his
name was Glenn I was like okay have I
ever witnessed a character in anime
history named Glenn have you ever heard
of any character building an anime in
Saitama thing there could be more basic
I think there need to be more like
really basic white people Dame's four
protagonists like Jean who's gonna save
the day let's it's called it's called
John chuckling speaking of Saitama
Briggs there's actually a hentai anime
that is brand new which represents a say
Tamil welcome did take login to us boys
the street guys are watching it go yeah
weird it wha I couldn't live in slacking
on my hand Tyler seasons because the
sexy model it it's uh it's the it's the
one with a bald guy and he's loving love
the one with a bald guy who looks like
say Tama yeah I think that's the sexy
monkey show that I mentioned and oh yeah
yeah
it just to be honest obviously many
people call it that I'm young
it's just actually where you actually
get to see the boobs made like new
so it's uncensored as edgy yes it's like
high school - did ya like the uncensored
version yes I've never seen the censored
version of club not nothing fancy but is
this a together were you talking about
the sexy mark gust avenjet is Glenn
isn't normal protego
[Laughter]
Glenn I can't even I know all right
another weird series that I've come
across watching is ittle manga sensing I
don't know if you guys are overweight
anyone not not not skip skip that one we
will talk about that one I just want to
say one thing about a certain character
called mega mean why in the world did
she say that she likes dicks
this is why which is exactly what I was
you had to go straight there some people
like next now the thing is I'm just
going to the weirdest points of the city
sites like oh yeah all girls my age like
dick and I'm just like oh okay I mean
the thing is how old is she she's like I
don't know 14 30 she's like 13 14 or
some [ __ ] she's like yeah all girls my
age love dick well I'll get the back I
don't I don't think that's a thing
anyway thankfully no one makes money
from YouTube anymore anyway because this
[ __ ] just got age-restricted real fast
yeah I know anyways next up is sin
Jackie no vomit virgin soul anybody
watch the first season actually this is
the Amana man I haven't seen it but I've
heard good things about it I've heard it
it's one of the best animes out right
now so another one that I want to check
out I also want to say by the way that
supreme Koon over there in chat Leslie
has been trying to get so they trying to
get me to notice him for like 18 minutes
straight and he wants us to answer the
question what is our favorite
slice-of-life anime
oh man and there's too many there's
really too many my favorite would be
Conan after story but I also love Otto
Hana quite a bit and Angel Beats so yeah
but probably cannot answer story overall
because of that ending doll and it's a
tie between after story and Little
Busters have any of you seen wound
Buster's I have not listened to the
music though great OST the music is
amazing like Jun Maeda just like takes
your texture takes your heart gets a
sledgehammer and he just hits it
repeatedly and I let it happen
that's great watch Little Busters though
that's it's a good time alright uh yeah
going back to Shinjuku no Mohammed it's
actually one of the best video game
adaptations out there it's done so well
and really enjoying the second season
actually but to be honest we don't see
the main character much often his name
is pawel he's not really included
because the main character is a is a
girl judging from the cover of course
but uh other than that it's it's very
enjoyable you need to watch it if you
haven't
plus it's by a man anime strike so [ __ ]
and no yeah it's by animation showing
[ __ ] anime strike you say [ __ ] Amazon
yeah this guy hates forum literally I
hate your Amazon I have not heard a
single positive thing about anime strike
what I hear that's like these were
streaming service LeMans on it is it is
I don't pay them anything I'm like okay
you know what I'll just wait for other
enemy sites to get it because Funimation
crunchyroll don't air any anime that
enemy Shrike owns so I'm like just go
and go go anime our enemy Russian watch
them oh yeah go go anime more like no no
anime no no there it actually is this
anime more likely missed me with that
[ __ ] ah the first season doing it I
just want to say that I do not endorse
use of anime recon whenever he says that
thought that's what I mean what do you
mind if Amazon wants to sponsor me I'm
holding yes let it diffuse visited by an
American I realize that the entirety of
the Red Cafe stream that is all I ain't
sponsoring [ __ ] you get it wrong if
amazon spot a sponsor me I'd be like
anime struck is the [ __ ] man
proud supporter and paying customer
crunchyroll I just want to throw that
out there yeah I have a virtual myself I
must rank you I like like I like their
streaming service I don't like your
[ __ ] Awards but I like their
streaming service
yeah the awards are another story but
they had the best streaming app to me
like I like there's a lot more than
Funimation the automation app hurts me
hurts the Silk cuts do it but with
undead wolf Amelia in the chat says
grimoire of zero is good and that's
another one that I've heard good things
about I know week on you're watching it
so tell us yes a grower of zero many
people can say it is close to being very
similar to our easy row since it's by
the same creators white fox who made a
reason it's it's it's a really good
fantasy anime but I need to mention of
course [ __ ] anime strike again for
owning this anime cuz literally I just
hate them every time I see animation I'm
like [ __ ] you animate strike but other
than that I'm really enjoying this
series because I don't know if you guys
don't watch it do you
nobody watches it yet your was yes like
normal but uh really like the characters
specifically for mercenary and Reiser Oh
have you guys played Skyrim before yeah
I have there is actually a Skyrim
reference in one of the episodes where a
guy said I used to be a Mercer like you
once but then I took an arrow to the
knee and instantly I was like some
Skyrim reference 20 look all they want
the veins back I was so surprised I was
literally in this series like I've never
seen that before but uh there is a bunch
of weird stuff in the anime as well like
um zero absolutely have has like a soft
fur fetish fetish for a you know
mercenary like she loves to be on top of
him and you know do weird stuff though I
mean I don't know it's she's a lolly of
course and so Briggs what animated you
like this so much trash you should know
it's not yeah no it's not it's just a
really good no no fairies at lolly as it
sounds pretty trash let me just say yeah
like I'll be honest I'll be honest as a
non-fan of lollies that kind of makes me
not want to watch the show
yeah that's one of my biggest pet peeves
I just can't I can't get down with that
[ __ ] no like me neither
I'm like I like the opposite I like like
like in have you have you seen have you
seen um what's it called Gadara Lotus I
have not
oh you know in that show my favorite
girl is the one guy's mom that's all I
guess Stacy's mom cuz I heist
hey speaking of mine hyouta satoru's mom
was probably the best thing about
[ __ ] uh erased
to be honest lists on that woman I mean
boy uh I I feel I haven't watched her
off for the stupidest reason it's
because one of my ex-roommate's was
watching it she loved it and she always
called it dirt for short she's like I'm
watching dirt Mike no f off like that's
stupid don't called her so I just
refused to watch it no it's only it's
actually in some of the like screens
like when the transitions from halfway
it they have the just up letters the
like and it's like more cycling to
[ __ ] personation well then it's like a
motorcycle go that's probably what do
rod Reagan comes from can you uh can you
do that again and let me record it so I
can use it as my ringtone forever
that'd be great just actually talk on us
it's not anime sauce it's not not weird
I promise I just want your voice is my
ringtone yeah yeah no I actually use
that anime stop saying it's [ __ ] sorry
well you got rid of the code geass it's
actually Death Note
uh oh I'm sorry I failed you in a Mac
I'll never do it again okay with a small
red penguins burn red says greetings
from Korea either that's an alias for
simply rose or we got another person
watching from Korea what's love and
isn't it like 6:00 a.m. 6:30 a.m. in
Korea right now huh it is 6:30 a.m. in
Korea and what was the night our still
spooky but awake by the way bricks
bricks
did you notice that every channel that
Creek
Pelham becomes a moderator for blows up
yeah I gotta get her in on your channel
streams
yeah man creep Ellen good luck creep
Ellen is good luck we're all we're on
promoter she is that subscriber of all
times I guess that means I should start
streaming in make her a mod don't you
say that I saw green creep Ellen was
actually a guy judging by the username
yeah coz Ellen Oh everyone's a guy or a
girl you know I like the first bucket a
girl's name back to me yet
I thought you other dude haha looks like
I wasn't the only one
though I slick on internet I anime the
majority of my subscribers are guys like
word like I just assume everybody I
encounter on the Internet to do yeah
that's the safe way to go I left status
otherwise otherwise right
that's a rule of yeah just assume
everyone to do it unless proven
otherwise
yeah I'm patiently by the garbage [ __ ]
and most of my subscribers are dudes but
uh but why the hell out your gender you
might get fooled you might get fooled
because maybe a guy has a picture of a
girl and yeah you might think it's a
girl but no it's actually a dude yeah
you mean like soul maka or cyanide
blizzard yeah yes exactly like 90% of
the people in your discord server and
the Ranji Matt :
oh yeah I mean I'm guilty too but I mean
it's different yeah you look a friend
with a mustache John as his profile in
the way really like like bring-bring
Bryn spent Brinton yeah yeah like did
you watch did you watch max video for
anime clickbait uh I don't think so I
don't want you to either in that video
and that video Bryn has like a fake
mustache and she says that Mac needs to
shave his mustache because she can only
be one mustache he's a bad image I put
it as his robot fish seems legit
but way too spooky says that creep Ellen
is solely responsible for his success
and I believe that video though just
right oh yeah guys good things are
happening for the rant cafe crew
Kahn is growing well as well Mack is
about to be cosplaying as RAM it's a
great time absolutely and of course we
all at all to creep Ellen and some other
people as well but mostly creep Ellen
and by the way yeah we do have now girls
who are fans of our channels and we call
them girl Bros in our discord we call
them girl bro someone just asked me deep
voice just asked me if I watched Alice -
Xue Xue Roku you guys I don't know if
you guys watch Alice Alice - Zuko
have you heard of it I think it reminds
me of like what I haven't seen it but I
but I've heard of it and remise you're
like ooh sake drop yes yes it does
series is really it's very good I really
it's by j.c.staff it's like it's good
it's good spike conscious person for
longer so basic basically about this
girl her name is sana where she
possesses this power called Alice's
dream where people are actually
researching about her in a laboratory
and she escapes and she meets up with
this old man named Naraku who then
becomes like a caretaker and basically
Zuko is a florist and you guys know what
floors is right they are they make
floors the floor that Moore's mmm I said
it's forest not for florists make floors
right
no a total ORS they make like they
prepare gifts and flowers and all the
stuff but um he becomes like her
caretaker and he has a granddaughter
named
Sanae so basically he calls her Sanne he
calls the main character at Sun and
sunny which is the granddaughter I mean
I was a little bit confused at first but
it then makes sense and then they have
their adventures together and she got
kidnapped and yeah that's basically yeah
someone compared it to like elfin lead
but like uh elfin lean unless looks like
there's barley blood and gore and that
was all openly it's pretty [ __ ] up
yeah you know good
way definitely yeah yeah but I see see
we're not casuals bro it's just that
we're the type of dudes devilry watch
fooly cooly randomly moving there it is
i watch great teacher onizuka like seven
times see actually recorded the whole
video but I don't know if I posted that
cuz I make so many videos I just scrap
but I actually did a whole video talking
about how it's hard for me to be a
seasonal ham a watcher cause I'm always
getting caught up of going back and
rewatching older [ __ ] or wanna watch
something from a previous season that I
missed it's difficult so hard-knock life
first world problems man just upload it
like you can think I I like think twice
when uploading some [ __ ] I upload come
on I'm just I'm really picky like I'm
such a perfectionist oh no oh yeah you
can't be a precious on YouTube because
it's like either way no matter how much
you try to be a perfectionist six months
later you watch one of your old videos
you're like what the [ __ ] was that
I mean this is a hundred percent fact
but I got to do the best I can at any
given moment and we have side I blizzard
joining us what up bro oh right on time
tonight yeah yes I know it's busy - he's
got a lot of work stuff but he said
he'll pop in if he can and he joined us
that's why I made sure to include the
link in the description to his channel
as well and of course guys as always
everyone link everyone's link here is in
the description to their channels they
are all quality animate youtubers yes
thank you okay
but um you should get back to work
though seriously no no seriously you
need to get back to work we need to get
that finished by tonight you could job
with pizza though yeah it's what's one
step up okay oh hi guys I didn't see you
there hello
lol you are what you do yeah so sighs I
won't ask your impressions of this
season so far what are you watching what
are you because I know Sinai by the way
guys does first impressions on his
channel so he watches a lot of new anime
at least the first episode so tell us
yeah wreck Olaf good are all filthy
casuals no gosh you know it's actually
been a pretty slow start and then my
workout bogged down so I've actually
been doing even less I was also changing
it's in my format so
it's unfortunate but um let's see I know
I've actually been pretty pleased
usually it's a case of where spring and
fall generally tend to be the stronger
seasons with summer and winter usually
being to lesser extents that's usually
how it goes this winter season actually
wasn't too bad so um one of the surprise
ones a lot of people have been talking
about is the grimoire of zero that one
that's actually been doing pretty well
uh let's see another one is Xu Mott
tsunami uh sheath Matsu Cobb blah blah
blah dadadada
Abby surprisingly good yeah super suka
yes that's actually been really good
surprisingly so did not expect that
that's from satellites and they
primarily been doing Macross lately but
uh they did a really remarkable job with
it the first few episodes have been
quite strong um good character
development
you know it's touching as well you get
the feeling that it's going to be tragic
but I don't know who knows but it yeah
it's it's really been impressive those
two been the big ones I've seen people
talking about so yeah see I hear on the
one hand I hear good stuff about
grimoire zero and then on the other hand
uh recon is like oh it's a bunch of
furries and Wally's gonna like gosh it's
I didn't say much remodeling the
selection of furries and lollies I said
zero the main character has a fetish
there you go yes exactly she has a very
fetish on mercenary the white tiger well
she actually thinks of him as a bed and
she's like you're warm you're
comfortable I'm gonna lay on top of you
he's like hey please don't she's like
suck it up [ __ ] hahahaha know it
basically mom not a lot but in the in
the world yeah it's it's interesting
because beasts fallen which is what
they're considered they're they're born
from humans but because of a curse or
something they look like beasts and
they're they're more powerful than
humans so as a result they're feared and
they're hunted by them both by humans
and witches so you have sort of a
difference where there's humans there's
witches and there's beasts fallen and
it's sort of trying to come
just in a world that's established
around it so it's it's really kind of
interesting to see how that interacts I
don't know how far in depth the anime
will go in comparison to something like
the light novel which is the source or
even how far that goes but it's it's
really interesting when you see rules
that explore that dynamic in a fantasy
study by the way sign that I want to ask
you this how was your reaction to the
Skyrim reference in one of the grand
more episodes if he's apparently
important to uh I think herps tweeted
out I know how legit it is but
apparently that's actually in the show
it's an actual line it legitimately
translates with that so yeah I saw that
I first I was like why would somebody
put that in there why we getting memes
in our subs happy I don't need ink iris
yes I have that's good but then I took
an arrow to the knee so I couldn't
decide it in yelling the right thing
that was such a metal [ __ ] I like it
um what else was I gonna say we have a
lot of [ __ ] in the chat talking about
fairytale love and fairytale hate in
fairy tale just like novels off topic
guys novels on topic the chat they're
always bitching at us all read copy
always goes off topic now we're done
with seasonal anime their time with a
very talented Bleach
what's up now guys hypocrite ass [ __ ]
call the fairytale haters hashtag [ __ ]
the fans
knock on door damn hey I don't get the
hate for Fito like it's not a good
series
I guess anime it's a fun series I mean
granted I haven't read or watched Fairy
Tail in several years so uh it's
probably gotten worse over the years cuz
it's got nothing but were some sting but
um yeah like I'm going on sword art and
in fairy so like it's the worst anime
ever and I'm like I'm kind of
exaggerating but clearly they have not
seen chaos dragon oh hell no that was
probably the worst anime I've seen
[ __ ] yes to give up one of his
friends to fame power like one that's so
bad that's so badly planned whoever was
the author of this plan this series so
badly wrote it
apparently it personally I personally
don't mind ferret I watch like the first
50 something episodes like I wasn't
motivated to continue but like while I
watch it I didn't mind it so definitely
not worst one thing I saw on Twitter for
never world said the Tokyo ghoul 2014
and I live in Republic really man
because if thinking of worst enemy Tokyo
ghoul is like up there for me if not the
worst anime I got through like 7
episodes I was like this is just saddle
masochistic cannibalism it's the worst
try are gonna be edgy stuff I've ever
seen in my life no wonder people love it
on tumblr oh you'll love this on discord
somebody brought Tokyo ghoul Anna Matt
comes in he drops that down I was like
whoa I do not expect that level of
savagery it was great see ya I do have
the heart of an X ETA Phi level that is
a it I like Tokyo goo I like I didn't
read the manga I'll put that out there I
didn't read the manga for its I don't
know how like I have another head but I
thought it was like for him for what it
was I really enjoyed it like it brought
the feels it brought the feels good and
almost made me throw up when he was
getting tortured i legit almost threw up
I was like wow I'm impressed this show
almost made me belch good job show so I
mean really about a finger for control
oh I didn't realize I didn't say that I
just said use the country tracker
oh yeah it'll compete its job is just
for those two episodes were you like
getting tortured and stuff or like how's
your dozen Idol like overall I enjoyed
it I have been like the ending of the
second season like it really left me but
her at annoyed but wanting more but it
still be still brought the feels he's
carrying his dead friend through that's
what I think all I'm hearing is tumblr
tumblr or
email Kolar oh come on now well you know
speaking of torture you know it's
currently this season as well there's
this the show that that's too good it's
torture for Team B compared to anything
else
Sakura quest is delightful it's slice of
life but there's some great comedy uh
very well done as well
rising Lee so that that really caught me
off guard when I watch that did not
expect it to be so good as from PA works
it looks good it sounds good
characters are enjoyable is about a girl
and she's trying to find a job is having
terrible luck finding a job it's a call
from her agency it's like hey this place
they're looking for a queen and she's
like what okay and then she goes there
it's like no no I was looking for this
other person and the guy's like she's
been dead for 20 years watch
why did anybody tell me so and it does
it sort kind of plays up from there but
no it's it's got good shaping so far up
reminding a lot of people as Sherrill
Baco
they would watch that but uh definitely
feeling that one right now so youyou had
me a PA works like I'd give it a chance
just because it's p.m. just because of
the studio I got you yeah just because
it doesn't mean it's a good anime by the
way that's that's not I said she said
I'd give it a fair chance I know if it's
like like if it's PA works or if it's
key I will give it a i'll give it a very
very very very
speaking of ki have you guys seen that
news flitting around about this
potential new Angel Beats series yeah I
have really I heard something about like
a new Clannad series once it turned out
to be click big thank God I feel like
it's [ __ ] until I report on my
channel if I report on my show [ __ ]
until I say it is it yeah exactly that
is that should be like the slogan for
anime I'll purchase like anime opera is
[ __ ] hola sadism I'm just really
hoping that judges because yeah like
have you heard what's happened with John
Maeda recently no basically he's he
needs a heart transplant
oh are you serum yeah of all things a
heart transplant but John's resting yeah
that's ironic
yeah but he's he's doing alright like I
follow him on Twitter and it seems like
he's doing it but like if this man dies
what the hell am I gonna do with my life
he's crying I suppose you just buy fur
do my edits that's crazy well it was
what that was Satoshi Kon when he passed
away hey there hey dr. Perry mr. Toshi
Khan good good well I'm just saying
Satoshi Kon and CEO for the reaction my
apologies my apologies no I'm just
saying you know we
we know what happened to Satoshi Kon
he's no longer with us oh man this just
got real guys I'm sorry that's that's
entirely my fault
I take response take responsibility for
this talk it was it was actually matter
oh it's cool we can handle it we can
have we're not a bunch of tumblr people
we can handle actually that reminds me
recently one of the manga writers died
the the author forum heist constable of
the dead yeah that's gay Santa Rita I
was I was so sad to actually hear this
because I was like who maybe one day you
know probably guess second season of
high school of dead but until I heard
this I was like okay looks like we're
not getting at anytime sooner I was so
disappointed yeah high school that that
is one of those guilty pleasures that I
absolutely enjoy just like Keijo then I
feel like I want to see more of but
thankfully I do have soul maka into
discord who can who can help you with
like lack of such anime as K Joe and
high school did getting second seasons
soul can keep hold you over within
artistry
I'm so like the edgy king or some yeah
he's actually an artist of hentai he
draws on hi-oh story behind that you
could you do Commission's asking for a
friend to Commission's my friend he does
are you guys watching Anna night Balkan
lover tyrant the the best comedy
actually this season
oh no funny though not so funny because
that is literally what girls call I it's
so good to a point where it's actually
one of the one of my most personally one
of my most favorite comedy series just
because it's it's it's a proper comedy
it's the first proper company I've ever
seen
literally it includes a psychotic
yandere name economy who's in love with
the main character safety it's all about
this kiss know where goodie
an angel literally just goes to his door
goes to the main characters door and she
just says kiss me or I'm gonna die
notice she
I was like why it's just the thing is
with that kiss know that she has she
writes anyone's name so this is it's all
about shipping basically she just ships
two people three or even four people
then you can just be widowed and they
have to literally kiss each other or
they're gonna die but in recent episodes
I don't really wanna spoil too much
because I'm pretty sure you guys have a
heart attack after 45 seconds
no no heart attacks I really don't have
spoil too much because you guys need to
see this
honestly you have to see this haven't
know Kiko I gotta say your tastes are
[ __ ] that show is awful what are you
talking about I mean the show is awful
cyanide yeah it is one note and then we
find out that she apparently likes the
main character who happen to like her
too and she's like oh you know and then
the joke is she's constantly stabbing
him and trying to kill him but he can't
die because oh [ __ ] dairyman then the
is that looks like a devil was actually
a nine young shining on the outcome that
the sister two of the ended a who
actually likes her book about blood
siblings okay delicious long as they're
not [ __ ] you shut the [ __ ] up
because I'm the reason why he doesn't
dies because he received the Angels
blessing so was she closely just staff
doesn't know yeah they know it's just
I'm gonna stab you mean like this
something interesting I remember reading
on the manga I was like I'm really
disappointed
wait you read the manga yeah and you
were disappointed yes well for an anime
only I like you thoroughly enjoyed by
this series it's probably one of the
greatest comedy in my opinion even
though those two sisters are not
blood-related who gives a flying [ __ ]
okay no one no one gives a flying [ __ ]
to your dad me neither is over is it my
day just happened to be not blonde right
I'm gonna say this guy's I've seen this
plot before except it wasn't you need to
kiss him to not die it was something
else and it wasn't quite your mainstream
animate that I've seen but I'll leave it
at that
okay I don't know any more cyanide
because you know we just got that
friendship show let's let's just drop I
know I know it's wrong
so thank you potential first impression
combiner you the ultimate impression so
have you done the first impressions for
when I Vulcan yet no I have not that we
should probably do that okay would you
be arguing okay best video ever I'm like
Michael
I like how deep voice in the chat is
like Anna Mac no spoilers bro even
though I haven't seen any of shrinking
animation
it's like those brothers to me and you
know yeah like how recon and and sign I
had this dynamics like oh the Skyrim
reference all yeah cool the best friends
and it's like what I like [ __ ] you man
like what don't watch great [ __ ] you
don't notice I'm just joking around
that's cool you know your mom like in
your own thing doing your own thing so
and by the way by the way um two things
first of all can someone please get
Mackel knots reaction right after I said
that girls call me love tyrants because
it's reaction was something along these
lines so please find that [ __ ] and
second of all on boo in the child was
saying recon like do you like every
animate this season that you watch or is
there anything you don't like there's
actually something to have a pretty
positive pain on everything no no not
everything is actually some series that
I did not enjoy from watching the first
episode I just dropped it let's say suka
Momo hashtag trash frame arms girls
hashtag trash um what else this one bite
away animation second ahsoka though
hashtag trash um what else um some other
stuff like twin angel break hashtag
trash
there's a local there's like a lot of
there's like a few series that I just
didn't find enjoyable but the main ones
that like hook me and I'm like okay I'm
watching that
yeah okay creepella looks like it's
going to bed goodnight creepella and
very nice creep okay or even with the
Roman section is hashtag drives right
now yeah I just ratchet
no but that's cool I respect that
recon cause if you should if you don't
like some of them you do say it you're
open about it cuz I know some youtubers
are like oh I like everything but you
are honest so I appreciate I'm just
honest I'm just leaving my open on
opinion I don't um I don't mean to
offend anyone but I respect everyone's
opinion but for me I just did not really
enjoy those episodes not your opinions
[ __ ] everybody in your opinion I think
you're why much my wife arias is not
[ __ ]
you you wanna have another wife of war
uproarious is okay but Ram is not a
great statement okay thanks for bringing
it
I'm one big brother um by the way soul
Mach I see you're back in the town I'm
trying to gauge the Commission's bro
trying to get you some commissions and
also guys just to let you know our
discord server is only about forty
people away from 1,000 and that yeah you
know what that means at 1,000 we are
hitting up a all-day discord party so I
don't know when it's gonna be maybe even
as soon as the weekend after this one
but you know when we reach a thousand
but get ready for that hype and of
course if you're not in the disc or yet
the link is in the description it's
crazy now like any time of night I wake
up I look at this score there's Chad
going on there's Chad almost all the
time people are on all the time it's
such a fun time so be sure to come and
join us if you like chatting about anime
everyday even Briggs I've seen a lot
online a few times I kind of best I see
on there once it was awesome yeah and
we're also working to organize gaming
stuff as well so we've got a little bit
of variety so even if you get a little
tired of the anime moving the games but
definitely a diverse amount of action
ships as well uh both the waifu husbando
and actual nice folk kind so the actual
one the the actual like nice awesome
book the kind with the handling all that
oh everything every type of shipping we
have these oh this thing is by the way
the reason cyanide blizzard did not say
anything harsh about the lollies and
furries is because he himself as a thing
for furniture or so I've been told
oh really someone explain to me the
origin of this table [ __ ] [ __ ] literally
people were talking about table [ __ ]
when I when the vicar was first created
and I just changed my name the table
[ __ ] and then it stuck
that was it that was literally this
table so the total [ __ ] itself was a
joke from Code Geass because Nina
proceeds to pleasure herself yes God
while looking at a photo so it that's
sort of where the whole thing kind of
originates from celty and originally it
was uh Nina someone actually named
themselves Nina in there and it was Nina
X table but then Nina went off in their
own direction and I found a plate of
curry
Couty and now it's big things get kind
of crazy as you can tell it's a fun time
there you know you never know what to
expect
yeah and if you think we're insane
because you don't get these inside
references you have you got to be part
of this court there you go
you got to be in the know to know you
know young not McClellan busy with work
lately so he's probably like his he's on
this core business of his works for like
what the [ __ ] is going on yeah I'm I'm
out of the loom I don't know what's
gonna go there tonight maybe I get yet
but sounds good Mack who are we shipping
Mack was anyone guys mmm looks like it's
Mack getting shipped let's not do this
oh he hasn't man he needs to be but we
should show you actual bonus and I'm
sorry system was in the description
let's let's see what great ships we can
come up for Lotus let's listen I knew
this but I think shipping is [ __ ]
stupid I hate yes fish yeah but yeah
you're an attractive young man thank you
you're good for quick anime fan you're
good anime taste you have a great intro
debatable also debatable now so that now
we have to we have to ship your sorry
man you have to it's called equal
treatment if everyone else gets [ __ ] you
gotta get [ __ ] how about you ship me off
to Japan that is a good one I want I
want to go
doh gonna write this down
stay on bodies again just send Lotus to
Japan
[Music]
what aloneness what country are you in
are you in Canada - no I'm in North
America I live in the States okay yeah I
see seems like so many people that end
up on Randolph they are from Canada like
90% like yeah I I I never notice that he
just brought it up Wow holy [ __ ] you're
right
yeah like last week we had a Jojo and I
didn't know he's from Canada oh yeah I'm
like all [ __ ] and like it started with
just a bunch of us Katy as it was it was
me Mac grin and Rose all of us from
Canada and then later on sign I joined
he's from the states and recon is
originally from the states now he lives
in England but Briggs is from Canada as
well so yeah a lot of a lot of that
Canada hey cuz you know what it gets so
cold there's nothing else to do but
watch anime it's what it is
I understand see me I just have to left
that's why we're so good at anime so
good at editing that's good we're all
watching each other show the season much
good very anime
yeah well Briggs let's cut brick some
slack he has to catch up to one piece so
nice Desai watching within lace bra
Lotus nah I fear if you're on one piece
on your channel is now over I never
really ripped on one piece is fight
fight I just make it very apparent that
I'm not a fan because I'm not and it's
the thing like I'm sure you're a great
guy
he knows my first time ever talking to
you one-on-one or not really one-on-one
but you know man-to-man
but I'm a fairly small channel you know
so there's not a ton of people I'm in a
decent side you know 4,000 subscribers I
usually get very little to absolutely no
hate on my channel whatsoever but on the
rare occasion that I ever get any
negativity it's always a one piece of it
it's only one piece fans it's always one
piece but I don't I don't know what the
issue is with the one piece fan base but
they're by far the most hateful people
I've ever met in this anime community I
just it's wild to me this puts me off in
the studio I don't like a suit
anyway that's even more discouraging for
me oh dude I found it really funny what
everyone like I found history based
anime like um jiu-jitsu no Maria or Jojo
sin Chi when I did first impression to
those and I wasn't a fan of them that's
like the most negativity I've ever
gotten the amount of people that would
be upset about it just always amazed me
it's it's incredible it's only then
history driven show is - it was like
well yeah but you see what's funny about
that I don't even have to say anything
about negative one about one piece I can
just say I like Naruto and then one
piece fans come at my neck and I'm like
oh did I do alright one piece is
significantly better than ours Elsa I
could give it boy
fight fight fight no but at least Naruto
doesn't take 500 chapters to get to the
hashtag good part it never does Oh next
because I like you not like I liked my
father I write I had to read the manga
it was like the filler takes up 45% of
sugar okay we'll see we'll see first of
all I I don't watch well I didn't watch
like the not side of it like I stopped
watching about to animate when I was
like 12 or 13 I was a manga only reader
for like the past I don't know almost 10
years or whatever at least it was it was
actually it was an enjoyable read yeah
the manga I mean I can't speak on the
enemy obviously it's no plagued by
fillers so it may be the anime is trash
I don't know I was a manga reader I
watched key episodes like certain sites
and of course I'll watch the final fight
between Naruto and Sasuke and she'll
like that but in the wedding but um and
I think you publish it I completely
disagree with 500 chapters to get
started getting good like I will that
was invented by boy oh look I read the
first people save one and it was a you
are like I don't disagree drop it I'm
down for this drama well most people
speaking go ahead are we actually gonna
rank on rank a no it's like most people
say that it gets good once you they get
the grand line because they're still
like kind of starting to form the crew
in the beginning and in the grand line
when they start their adventure
more or less but personally the are long
arc the brought ta our course on my
favorite arcs in one piece
she here's my thing right so the grand
line arc like or when you get to the
grand line that you're about I don't
know 10 11 cuz that's around the time
that I actually quit it's ironically um
you get to your like 10 11 12 volumes
somewhere around there when you get to
that point in the story I look at that
and I'm like hmm
death notes good death notes an amazing
manga it's only 12 volumes the entire
thing is the good part one piece should
not take this long to get to the good
part that's kind of my stance on that
yeah I I agree kind of got to the good
part I enjoyed the rest myself like
myself like it wasn't bad for me well I
don't think it was bad either if I'm
buying why was it good by the way guys I
like this I'm not really a big fan of
either and I haven't caught up to either
however because I like views and drama
and [ __ ] we can have a rank of a where
lotus and soul maka both haters of one
piece take on Briggs and 2spooky huge
lovers of one piece hmm how did I mean
who doesn't give a [ __ ] about either see
I'd be down for that but moderator they
probably have an advantage over me
because they've seen more Bernard so
than I've seen up one piece in but or or
reddit so I don't know like I don't know
how I could back up arguments but it is
well you gotta back up your argument
because you said you seen you read the
first 100 chapters right oh yeah
somewhere a little on here
like the last check last chapter I
really remember reading is like Luffy
fighting some giant [ __ ] whale or
some [ __ ]
yeah well that's that's enough middle or
right when you enter the grand line yeah
that's what I said it's like you know
tender so volumes in that's right we're
like okay this [ __ ] fighting a giant
Wiggly cross red line fight the whale
booboo I remember his name oh my god I
really loved that pretty the way laughs
he hasn't seen this again plus I'm a
shallow ass [ __ ] and I care a lot about
aesthetics and I think one piece artists
trash but that shows me does I agree
with that I don't like the article it's
off-putting the manga is trash I'll say
like the animation in art style and like
the anime is pretty trash but I mean the
animation manga he's like I've seen some
good sock before like it flows really
well and the best accountant directors
and key animators but like the art style
I don't like a trio like he's
he's not talented he's not a talented
artist cuz the style is what it is and
I've seen dope drawings of one piece
from metro to Oda but his his style for
it overall I'm just not a fan I think
it's really ugly and I know he
intentially designs his characters to be
goofy and silly and look the way they
look to make them more unique and set
out also the [ __ ] that's cool you know
if you like that su I think it's ugly I
think it's really ugly it's very
off-putting for me some people really
dislike the characters
personally I think Oda is more
consistent than kishimoto I don't know
if you've asked couple hundred the 200
chapters of Naruto were very like
disappointing to me in terms of art
style I don't know if you agree with
that uh it's been a while since I read
it because I was reading it we tweaked
but what I can say is that because I do
own the first 48 volumes and then I
won't bunch that miisu I don't have this
third box it but um I will agree that I
definitely like his art style more in
the first part like when they're all
younger so 1 through 27 and then earlier
on in the bombs as compared to like the
final cuz I'm looking at it and part of
it is the fact that North was started
out being hand-drawn then the transition
to digital as the times went on and that
changes our cell but I definitely do
like his earlier style and it was
probably more consistent and it was
later on all I'm saying is guys God
knows we're running out of ideas so why
don't we just have this show down soul
maka says that he can carry you Lotus
that he's done a lot of thought thinking
all right Mothe had no time I already
know exactly what he's gonna say I see
him chirping in the discord good at that
that's what we want we want that drama
what feed me feed me that drama oh yeah
we got it we got to do this pen we got
to do this we got to do this we got to
build it up we gotta make a huge debate
and it has to be ethical ethical ethical
nice hashtag epic oh um it was something
else I wanted to bring up oh yeah
supreme saying notice me I already
noticed you man everyone knows I already
noticed you who else
what else oh yeah by the way yes I just
remember are you lovely young lady
called AZ bash in our discord server
she's in the chat too but using a
different name she suggested that for
one ran cafe I think we're aiming for
July now we should have a bunch of
people in the discord right like a
one-page
sort of pitch for what kind of anime
they would want to see like I'm the
ideal anime they would want to create
and then we can you know what you know
what I love that idea because then I can
talk traffic like that's a shitty idea
that's a shitty idea that's generic
that's cliche I told you can come up
with something unique and I just got to
tear down every pitch that people throw
forth and be like hi it's generic cliche
boring your emcee sucks your waifu [ __ ]
let's do it
and it's like a ten-year-old who
submitted it Hey yes you today Hey but
yeah tomorrow so the idea is that we
have a few of the best ideas we read
them live on rank of a and judge witches
our favorite what do you guys think of
that exercise really dope I'm s yeah and
I think that was a Z bashas idea
although I know she was coming up with
this with other people but yeah I
nothing like the idea I think it's gonna
be a cool idea get everyone engaged get
a little competition again it means you
guys got to go join the discord to be a
part of it but it's a fun time on this
Court no I'm saying but we lost recon at
some point he didn't say anything he
just disappeared I thought it was going
to come back in but it kind of just
vanished I think it's because he
couldn't handle the cyanide blizzard
beets
it's too much you know you can do little
jokes but then it's like it all hit him
y'all hit on bro like love tyrant what I
I don't know if I can deal with this I
may have to go as well it's just you
know can't accept just can't deal just
weighing so heavily on your heart right
now it is let it burn let it burn girl
bro says girl bro so sign on your dream
crusher I am crazy
crusher dreams oh no but I love it it
says rant cafe guys it is Ranke Phil got
a ran sometimes Mac stop watching don't
come on oh sorry okay but I've told
myself that the next time I watch it it
it's about time to watch it again it's
about that time I'm gonna watch it and
sub it's gonna happen fifth time's the
charm here we go
I have a hard time transitioning you
think whatever I watch originally is
like set in stone from yeah and that
that's why I've only ever watched it in
English like ice
and watching it in sub once and like I
don't want to read today so I just watch
it in Devon just it was easier at the
time and I realize now because Anna Mac
makes me feel awful about myself every
time we bring it up but I ain't watching
sub and an accomplished that's what the
internet is for just to make people feel
bad about themselves yes and your story
I mean you feel good I mean if you're
not talking trash on the internet you're
not using the internet right yeah I know
like what do you what do you like
sending people Pinterest stuff like whoa
now YouTube videos of cats please whoa
now what yeah [ __ ] Pinterest man
okay that's I was just absolutely savage
why I'm not just interest if you want to
sponsor us I say I say I want a lot of
things on my gravestone but I think I
want that on my gravestone which one are
you max 20 like 994 to 2017 [ __ ]
Pinterest in quotes that's exactly I
think mostly women over 30 use Pinterest
that's what I have a god
I wasn't Mac do you use Pinterest no I
don't know where this is coming from not
not judging just asking you know no I
know I don't even my mom uses Pinterest
of that that helps too yeah graph there
it makes perfect sense also women under
12 love tumblr so there you go oh she's
sorry most people I know use tumblr like
over 12 they just complain like 12 year
olds there we go yeah so exactly yeah I
used to post my art book stuff on tumblr
was your pretend that doesn't exist
anymore
never happened it's not an actual thing
she's simply for animated photography I
don't know much about I don't know much
about um art books I know uh sign on you
are intimately familiar with the topic
thanks but yeah like I'm sure like for
certain niche interests on tumblr like
you can find some good stuff same thing
for like Pinterest if you're an artist
I'm sure it's a different game ball
just for me personally I have no
interest in any of those things like
nothing there that speaks to me I guess
it's a good platform depending on what
you're looking for right just like a
flower Queen else but I like I've used
it maybe once I've never had like a
tumbler but I've been on it like once or
twice and it's expensive like I said
appends on what you're looking for right
you have those he really does so which
is funny cuz my my sister got my mom to
use Instagram and my mom will Instagram
various other things and should make
collaborations it's funny to watch my
dad be around things my dad tell my mama
stop doing it my mom gives my dad a
dirty look then
so things those pops up so it's great
you know it's just a don't don't
interrupt me and do my Instagram like a
party on is that sir our ISM to track
got but yeah I I wasn't mostly like
parents like Facebook like they discover
Facebook and they just love it risky
pulls everything on their most cliche
[ __ ] it's just fun and then everyone our
age just moved away everyone our edges
on Twitter yeah yeah it's funny I saw a
tweet yesterday that said everyone who
didn't transition from Facebook to
Twitter in 2012 that's our ages now has
a kid and I'm like I'm looking on
Facebook I'm like oh my god he's right
so true is it is oh I'm looking at
everybody I knew in high school that's
still on Facebook like they they all
have children this it's a fact like if I
even notice I'm a joke it's just fact I
mean underneath book but I post like
once every three weeks I have a snack
checking to see what my friends back in
my home state are up to sorry anime I
cut you off there no no you didn't overs
at Mackel not die cut off or both oh
what's what Quist y'all remember when it
finds me I hadn't oh sorry
yeah see it's a curse I've spread the
curse it's a gift that keeps on giving
the gift of interruption that's at home
it's there to song is good now make your
microphone fall over how do you like
them apples
boom hashtag it's all me
to be fair there has not been one
episode of reco film max microphone than
folder twice you know it's it's it's
it's you know I'll have an excuse I'm
sorry my mic stand was lent out because
my one of my roommates is a sound tech
and he's like hey you have a mic stand
I'm like yeah he's like can I use it and
I'm like yeah so used it that's the
story
great story ten out of ten would telegin
would read again charging interest I
just like arm that manga maybe the words
manga ever oh my god the shortest manga
ever maybe make your thing soul maka I
need you to make the best hentai I'm
sorry I'm super tired it's been locked
you know you know you know you start a
sentence and you're thinking about it
and then it like it's just your brain
cuts out halfway through that's been you
what I like it that way
a hand tie about a mic stand I could see
some possibilities with that you know I
don't know if that's what you want you
left but if you're asking for it that's
the Internet will provide it dreams can
become a reality you too can have robot
porn huh well I can't wait till we're
all huge channels right and people dig
the subs like before they were famous
yeah but it's also gonna be funny cuz
everything literally everything you say
someone's gonna make a [ __ ] up fan art
of it and it's gonna be hilarious
was that a rule 34 is that what that is
yeah scared to herstory I've so far had
to fan fics made one with my previous
co-host and one with my first co-host
and then apparently someone talked about
making one of us Mackel not so uh dear
Lord I've had one made of me and I read
half of it and then I just kind of like
stopped this like hey I I like your
enthusiasm I dig your fire haha we have
an official discord fan think of like
the discord all this kind of stuff like
fictionalized as like a real Kingdom and
stuff like that and however I
quickly screen it before it is published
so I always look cool and awesome it
writes everything to make him badass
yeah we have like we have Soviet Union
style censorship over there and it works
great he really thinks he's lelouch us
Wow yeah man I do I do
thank you thank you you understand it's
abusing is yes I don't like this get him
out yeah
you're fired Ana Mack this is a mutiny
its coup d'etat taking over the old Hawk
me bro don'tdon't hock me yeah right
then he makes a bad pun get him out dad
leave that y'all remember the no tase me
bro like 10 years ago
don't hate me bro that names the new one
is don't hack me bro don't hack me bro I
mean it's a real concern on YouTube
nowadays yeah with everything with
Twitter with everything with people
getting out yet especially if you're big
enough for someone to care enough to
hack you you [ __ ] I don't think I'm
there yet yeah none of us is but break
soon we on the wings your own salsa I
want tweeted bomb threat from my account
to get me suspended on Twitter so you
know I'm basically there yes yeah yeah
yeah brick says some issues with a
splitter account so yeah he's famous
girls now that I see my fault though not
gonna talk about it I'm ready cheese is
talking about it
loss of 13 thousands of followers yeah I
mean I feeling on that but it means hey
at least you know well and that may not
equal out you've had massive growth on
your YouTube channel holy cow is true I
definitely care about my youtube channel
more it feels good yeah and it's just
good quality content man by the way if
you guys don't know Briggs does a lot of
research for his videos he does fact
videos Theory videos seven deadly sins
my hero academia right now are the big
ones but he's also seen seven deadly
sins is booming right now yeah but he's
also done a lot of other things as well
I know blue exorcist he was doing sword
art online recon fan service he's not at
all so definitely be sure to check him
out check him out and then tell him I
came here from Rand cafe so all your
success Briggs is
- Anna Mac that's where all my systems I
love you all I love you all I love you
all and you owe me everything not okay
but but um while we wrap it up I think
it's time to wrap it up slowly to do our
outro however I want I do want to say
Gilgamesh in the chat said who's seen an
anime that's also a hand-tied I don't
think I can even think of one but while
we do the otros guys think of some
possibilities for that and let me know
and Lotus we'll start with you just tell
us who you are and what you do and
remember guys all the links are in the
description to all these awesome
people's channels Lotus okay so my name
is Lotus the boy who never knows best
you can check me out over at then
Derrick ordinary corner where I do manga
hauls impressions videos I kind of was
doing anime reviews and [ __ ] for a while
but I kind of sucked away from that
might be getting back into it might test
out some live reaction type things we'll
see how that goes also do video game
content so if you like anime games like
Naruto or Dragonball and stuff like that
you can definitely come and check me out
over on my channel and uh yeah yeah he
just said what do you say this did
something that never knows best
yeah the book who never knows best the
bloke the boy the boy yeah reference to
fooly cooly right there and I'm also the
biggest fully [ __ ] fanboy on the
planet so there's that as well yeah he's
such a big full equal fight that I went
McMahon when I made my fully cool video
I messaged him I was like dude watch my
fully cool video tell me what you think
I'm desperate to know what you think
which is an amazing video by the way and
if you haven't seen it definitely go
check that video because it's really
well put together it's really
well-spoken really articulated he really
breaks down histories and explains that
anyone who thinks it's just random
[ __ ] because there is much more to
fully cool than just the seemingly
randomness that is on the surface in
there it does have something much bigger
than that
behind all that so go check out that
video because it's great thank you so
much boy like I said like I like
positive words from a big fan like you
mean so much to me so thank you and yeah
I got video like I was inspired to I got
goosebumps small like thinking about it
while doing it I really want it that's
for me that's what YouTube is all about
is right doing something you really love
and then having it turn out well and
just you know having a cool discussion
with people about it that's what it is
like if you if you don't do that
you
doing as you love it it's not gonna work
out because you have to be you know it's
a rough business it's not like YouTube
is not easy to be to make it to be
consistent to deal with haters and all
this kind of stuff but like one of these
fans right so even you gotta you gotta
love it and you gotta do what you love
and you really got to have a passion for
that shit's for you to get anywhere with
it absolutely and that's why that video
to me is kinda probably the one I'm most
proud of because it was such a I was
inspired I did it I did it in the way I
wanted to do it and yet for sure I'm
really glad you liked it
loved it homie thank you bro I love
having you here as well I love to have
you back let's go to anime recon oh he's
not here I'll just do it I'll just do it
what up everybody it's anime recon and I
do a lot of reaction videos I'd love my
boys my boys recon no pico Havok no pico
I do reaction videos I do top 10 lists
and yeah check out my channel dudes 3
solid solid well I would say you should
start it off what's up anime fans of the
world he doesn't say that does we yeah
he does it's hard to make out sometimes
majority of the time but yeah blue he's
excited
yeah yeah it's good by the way for
reactions right quick thing yeah quick
thing about reactions me and goes I
started doing real live reactions for
attack on Titan on Saturdays and some
guy who does like reaction mashups
actually like put us in one of his
mashups and of course that reaction
mashup has like eighty thousand views
and our reaction is like five thousand I
don't get reaction matchups like I don't
whoa I never really saw the appeal to
live reactions in the first place like
that's not disrespect people who make
them because I understand making them is
different like that's I think making one
be more enjoyable than watching one like
I don't and then i don't get combining
them especially like trying to sync all
that [ __ ] up how's that fun to people i
don't know it's way to me yeah like my
favorite of the ones is 18 plus people
in there yeah but if you know what i
think it is i think it's if there's like
an epic moment in the episode
shocker they want to see how everyone's
reacting to it you know like are they
reacting how I'm reacting not kind of
thing
but it's what I was gonna say is we are
just chill kind of watch cos we watched
it live Lotus and then we like Chad with
people doing it like we're not like pre
recording it like we're not a reaction
channel that's different right to hang
out with you so we're like oh man that
was cool that was crazy and these but
these are like oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] they were
there riding horses man I wish I were
and like you can't hear us at all that's
the whole point like industry after you
can hear yeah that's one of the thing I
was thinking about it's like okay if you
mash up multiple reactions you have
people talking in this one and people
talking this one it's like how's that
and you would watch because you have
people talking over each other it's
different for like a livestream where
you know someone starts talking some was
like kind of backs down like you can't
back down pre-recorded footage so like I
don't just seems like it doesn't really
work out to me I've never watched one so
this is coming from a man of ignorance
but I don't know I have no interest in
that yeah I don't really watch the
mashups either but there is appeal
because I think this guy gets like
50,000 views in like two days
Oh Mike Mashable one we actually he does
like a part 1 part 2 and part 3 oh just
for just a Dominic is milky I forget the
name like I saw us they're like [ __ ] man
like we're clearly under reacting we're
just like Sheila knows our [ __ ]
freaking out
oh by the way I need a clip of that hand
motion Mac did by the way thanks hey I
got you a little gin fit for your give
it give it give it
tomato tomato I got she's good good I
didn't see that I was too into my recon
impression what's going on this is a
subtle little hand motion you know just
very sensual you know oh nice
it's perfect okay let's go to Sinai bro
who are you and what do you do hi my
name is Ino you can sometimes usually
catch me in the discord
however I primarily stream on mostly o
su and Final Fantasy 15 right so you're
the real email I [ __ ] knew it
yes I'm currently using a voice
modulator to sound like cyanide blizzard
what do you think I'm testing it out I'm
gonna steal his channel don't tell him
if I'm gonna be taking over yeah well
that will be the best twit
for the first impressions are the creme
fraiche out in the end just email takes
over the whole channel faucet that would
be cool
although I don't know if you know will
do we have negative first impression so
she'll just feel like oh this is cute I
like it love the way to come out now
I've ever running bad to where I know
probably just gets like lividly pissed
off it's lightening some you wouldn't
expect just BAM just right there and
you're like wow I love see her she's
freak like just go full Brad well yes oh
come on Mac Allah to you my friend
Oh me well that's my name and I make I
don't know man I I don't know what I
make I make I make like I basically take
whatever's been done content wise and I
make it not that and I'm just sarcastic
and satirical and all that jazz uh
there's I'm supposed to be doing a video
a week now it hasn't happened because
works been busy noob and things have
been busy but this Sunday new code geass
videos coming out for a legit theories
for code geass season 3 legit number 2
and then we've got apparently a ton of
vlogs coming out I hate vlog I hate
vlogging so much but there's some sick
fogs coming out in the next a little bit
as we'll one of which is anime north one
of which has 1 to 2 of the 5 people in
here no way five people math Raja Planet
three of us and we're gonna have actor
Maximus there as well at a time I know
it's gonna be a crazy ride so I would
looks like just a month away guys crits
less than a month now it's crazy so high
so I'm gonna meet you guys for the first
time got a bully you a chit can you try
and follow me a nice little anime north
collaboration oh yeah well Wednesday
Briggs ones too that one's not on my
screen sorry everybody everything frozen
right now I don't know
can you hear us
I see math on that blew my face haha
okay well on that no bricks tell us who
you were what you doing by the way just
to finish off max thing he also streams
on Twitch Jackie Molly those hilarious
stream at least once a week I believe
you're still that the once a week on
Sundays now it's once a week for now
hopefully during the summer I'll get
back to three maybe but we'll see how
that goes
yeah he's only busy faithful twitch
streamer I'm looking forward to a code
geass video I will see will compare
theories my friend will see who's more
legitimate and after your clickbait
video i hope you've learned some [ __ ]
and I hope this is gonna be a good
clickbait video I want to see some
Valletta I want to see some Colin I want
to see some c2 I want to see all their
boobs I want to see it man oh don't
worry the thumbnail is gonna be just
throw some psycho [ __ ] team in there
for me too okay thanks got yummy dig six
boobs at the minimal yeah you know be
very least nice tank Thank You Mack Ike
I'm counting on you and Briggs to you my
friend tell us who you are tell us what
you do and tell us when we're gonna do
some of that sound at least dreams I'm
hoping within the next week or so would
be the send at least in streams but yeah
I'm Briggs from all the anime I make
facts videos I like explaining like
anime concepts yesterday explained full
counter the move that Mellie Otis has or
ability that Mellie Otis has and the
send Effie sins I'm hoping to explain
some quirks from my hero academia mm-hmm
yeah that's about it but I want to just
add in my from my hero academia you guys
are saying you like the whole villian
stuff like more than the high school
just in general like look we look
forward to this season it's gonna have a
lot of the billet Alliance and oh yeah
I've read the mangas you're not like
with my school - yeah Oh what type I'm
fully caught out now on the mama I read
I waited for this Anna she's gonna come
out I got waited for the time to come
out I'll be patient I don't want to
spoil it for myself I watched two
episodes I'm like I'm dying well I read
a 135 chapters uh-huh nice
nice well you're a true fan and that's
that's what matters so I respected bias
with that type of show
Oh quick shout out to that amazing scene
I think it was in the second episode
with Todoroki that was animated by you
talking Nakamura with when he did that I
shouldn't froze like the whole ah okay I
loved that scene so much Heather Rose
I'm on the Greek on that's exactly how
excited he was
I'll keep Mary Rowe it was pretty high
yeah you know to each his own goals and
loves the show - I'm just not that big a
fan I don't know about we'll see I'll
keep watching it laughter I like him
Kenichi yeah well I would seek reach yet
I I think I might like that one too from
what he's told me but I will I will
check out Kenichi one day and then we're
gonna talk about it Briggs we're gonna
hug it out is gonna be great and yeah so
I'm gonna still keep watching my York
anemia hopefully I want to see the
villain stuff I'm interested in that so
I want to see it go crazy and yeah guys
thank you for joining me as well again
for another week 23 weeks now and it's
been a blast as ombu says not me ANBU
says this is the greatest anime podcast
of all time I mean he's in it too but I
say a - but that I always quote ANBU so
it looks like I'm just like you know the
movies what they're like best ever
the New York Times like that's the kind
of thing I'm doing well I so thanks
everyone in the chat who comes we got
the regular crew we got some new people
coming in it's always a pleasure to see
you all and hang out with you the
conversation will continue on this Court
right after this so come and join us and
until next time everybody
see ya space cowboys bay
[Music]